♪ (intro music) ♪
If you're displaying images
downloaded from a network,
wouldn't it be great
if you could put in a placeholder image
while you wait for it to download?
Fortunately, you can with FadeInImage.
You can specify a local placeholder image
from the assets directory of your app,
or you can do it from memory.
Set the height and width parameters
to determine how much space
the image should take up
before and after loading.
Use the fadeInDuration parameter
to specify how long
the animation should take.
Set the fadeInCurve to specify
the way Flutter should animate
the replacement of the placeholder image.
If you just want your placeholder
to be a transparent image,
check out the transparent_image package.
For more info on FadeInImage
and all the other Flutter widgets,
go to flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪